and we had struggled a lot and we'd been
through a lot at that point
um as just as a family and my mom
working you know three jobs just to keep
us
in our house and you know we were on and
off food stamps for a bit like it was
it was just it was a time and so there
was this
you know um yeah well what did your dad
do
my parents were divorced at that point
and he stayed in louisville
he stayed in louisville yeah oh man
yeah so that was the other thing that
you know we were all
it was it was it is just so wild to
think about
all of that now and how many
people helped us along the way and how
many
like i think about roe now i think about
this holding deal from warner brothers
now i think about
just everything that aligned for all of
us to be here it was
it was um it's really nuts it's kind of
a miracle
it is i mean the the chances of survival
in this
sound like we're going to the arctic the
chances of survival here in hollywood
it is like going into the arctic also my
mom was like a single mom she was like
you know i think i'm 40 i turned 40. you
look
by the way not hitting on you i'm just
saying you look fantastic i would have
thought
32 oh michael no you look great is that
now is that really good lighting because
you
you do look great oh god thank you so
much i feel i feel great i feel great
that's good but was it a divorce hard
for you as a kid
yeah divorce is divorce is awful
i don't divorce is awful yeah i went
through it too i went through a divorce
uh in fact i've been through oh my let's
see my sister has been
divorced four times my dad's divorced
twice my mom's divorced
anyway i you know i i get that but how
old were you when they
when they split up 12. well that's got
to be incredibly hard
yeah it was it was i uh
i it's really really hard divorce is
just really hard
um i went through one myself um
a few years ago and i i
i think as a kid um
there was a sort of pressure that maybe
you you want to be i know for me i kind
of wanted to be everything to both of
them
i wanted to help them that was my
feeling was like oh i want to help
you know you heal and i want to help you
heal and i want to like
everybody's hurting and this yeah it's
just a
it's just a really complicated hard
thing to go through and and
but also i think sometimes
for the best as hard as it is
it's it's not necessarily the unhappy
ending
um oh yeah do you see signs as a 12 year
old because i saw signs when i was a kid
and i was like these people should not
be together
i knew that my parents shouldn't be
together so it didn't
shock me which shocked me as th they
were together as long as they were
so was it was yours shocking or was it
dysfunctional
not shocking at all i remember i think i
remember sort of thinking like
i was surprised it it it hadn't happened
yet but i think there was
um like i remember they separated once
when i was about eight
and i was so devastated that
i i don't have a ton of memory from it i
just remember like
my brain exploded and i remember just
being so
overwhelmed at that thought and i
actually think my reaction is one of the
reasons that they were like
okay we need to uh we need to maybe we
need to smooth this over for now you
were so devastated that your parents
probably got back together that was
probably the reason
i was probably the reason that they were
unhappy for four
years my god yeah yeah i mean
that's that's tough but they both
supported your endeavors they both
supported you going out to los angeles
and yeah yeah i think for the most part
um um they were both
always i mean i i always felt that
support i mean i did plays
from the time i was eight years old and
um
that was always the one thing and i'm so
grateful i look back on it now i just
think about it's so wild when i think
about
my mom being my age and having like
teenage kids and making a decision to go
to hollywood with them
i it's so wild but um yeah there was
this
feeling that even in
everything my family went through in the
struggles that we had that we
we could still do anything like dream
big
um and and and so i i for that i'm just
incredibly grateful like nothing was off
limit so it's sort of that same thing
yeah do they talk still
were they friends did they do they talk
no
nothing yeah mine don't either in fact i
always have this fear at my wedding i
i'd have to have two different weddings
because it'd be so uncomfortable
to have them both in the same room and i
really have
i've my therapist is like why are you
talking you're not even in
you're not even a committed relationship
let alone married and you're [ __ ]
worried about your
wedding and your parents being there
what this is anxiety out the ass
i was about to say michael i know
well anxiety i have it too though i
think about things like that all the
time and it's like oh my god wait this
isn't even a real scenario i don't